now we're starting a new work by
Kierkegaard fear of traveling this is
one of his major works and it gives you
some of the most important things that
you see running through this entire
corpus it ties them together doesn't
explore some of them in as a great
detail and as he doesn't and so on this
other tasks but this is a great fulcrum
point for thinking about the theme
religious in relation to the topic all
for Kierkegaard and even the instead
another lower stage of life for him what
I'm going to do is put this up into two
lectures the probe LaMotta sort of real
not all but a good proportion of movie
I'm going to actually talk about in the
next lecture in this lecture I'm going
to talk about some of the preliminary
material which turns out not to be quite
so preliminary there's a lot of meat
there he had about the structure of the
work and about some of the big
overarching themes and absolutely
central to this word is the biblical
story of Abraham and Isaac in it
Abraham one of the fathers of faith
great fathers of the monotheistic
religions is opposed with a terrible one
way to even say a horrible choice the
estimate and he chooses the right way as
we're told the story we'll talk a little
bit more about the particulars of that
for those who aren't as familiar with
the story he chooses the right way
interrelation to God but it's something
that's very difficult to wrap your head
around in one sense it's very easy the
story isn't actually not that very long
a lot of stories
but to put yourself in his position and
understand what was going on that's a
whole different ballgame
so we'll talk about that a moment before
that one of the notes that McKenna
doesn't use this term dialectic and walk
a lot in this this particular work but
his philosophy is dialectical and well
oftentimes it's framed is at the
Kierkegaard sort of the Antony Hagel
handle doesn't point the term dielectric
that goes goes all the way back to to
Plato and Aristotle but in modern times
dialectic comes to take about different
meanings there is one we called
dialectical philosophy and Hegel was
really at the center of early
dialectical philosophy and Hegel looks
at all the things that are important for
human beings art literature economy law
society family states pick whatever you
want even down to things like perception
and he sees them and processes in which
reason or consciousness where we the
human the distinctively human thing
about us works itself out dynamically
oftentimes through opposition's through
negations through the things being
placed in relation to each other and
then hammington sort of modify each
other
Kim Bergeron is doing something very
similar
he's very critical of Hegel a lot of
points for where Hagel has gone but he's
actually doing something not that
unlikely was there and the key things
here in this are what's the relationship
between philosophy and faith is faith
something that just precedes philosophy
which philosophy could work out
object and perhaps even improve upon or
its faith rather or something like a
limit or philosophy has to stop and
something else has to continue those are
live questions and part of the function
of the dialectic is to work that out
another thing that's not quite so often
talked about with respect to this work
but I think it's very important I'm
going to stress this number of times in
what is the relationship between
Christianity as a religion as a stance
as a way of thinking living believing
feeling doing relating oneself and human
life and gentleman with or without
Christianity so we're going to explore
those in just a moment so before we go
into the looking at the structure though
I want to get on some of the other basic
notes of this this moment like I said
Abraham is answering the central and the
question that Kierkegaard is trying to
wrap is covering up is what is Avery we
know he didn't he's a guy in a story
yeah you know we know what he is a sort
of model but really what is going on in
Hebron what does he stand for or better
yet what does he in a body that's an
open question should Abraham for example
if you looked at has something like a
like a tragic hero or a romantic hero
and we're gonna see their character
grades began to into this almost but not
there's something fundamentally
different for the tragic hero of the
Greek tragedy
the Shakespearean tragedy or any other
kind of tragedy there's something
different between Abraham and that sort
of figure if we think of tragedy in
terms of the life of the mind
Socrates for example Abraham is not
Socrates either and you can ask yourself
a question who's better who's greater
who action in bodies what is best in
human beings what is most fully human to
a higher degree Abraham or these other
figures Abraham was clearly also not a
poet Kierkegaard is going to talk about
the poet in here and he's actually gonna
figure it himself gonna serve as being
so so far we've all been just talk about
what Abraham is not we're gonna get to
whatever but this brings up another
important point another note two thing
to think about to consider before we
delve into is Kierkegaard or the
character who he is having speak on his
behalf
- hani's - Silencio the supposing author
of this book he is he actually a
philosopher in some sense clearly yes at
the same time he seems to be telling us
that he is not a philosopher and if you
think of philosophers along the lines of
say Descartes even Socrates let alone
contour Hegel or some of the academic
types of our own time it's a little hard
to place here the guard here
he has an actual philosopher on the
other key now there's good reasons to
think that he is a philosopher so we're
to explore that as well
another thing that he's going to stress
is and he's not gonna framing it as such
but but we can print it in terms of this
question what is philosophy about
fundamentally what is philosophy
concerned and here we can see
Kierkegaard just shining forth as an
existentialist water philosophy is not
just about linguistic questions it's not
just about abstract metaphysical
questions that have no connection to our
daily lives it's not just about systems
of ethics that you might get in a
textbook
it is about what matters most
philosophy is Kierkegaard conceded that
he and his Hegel disease and as Socrates
concern could have conceived of it is a
concern for what it is best
what is greatest how do we worry into
our lives it's a practical activity it's
not just a speculative activity for even
for Hegel it's a practical activity I
know a lot of people don't see it that
way but that is
through his work another thing that you
want to think about when it comes to
philosophy is is philosophy what has
been tamed and the books is it the
concepts is that the system of ideas is
it some sort of finished product which
then you can purchase and acquire and
assimilate and take on another way of
putting this with different metaphor is
if indeed there's progress and we stand
on the shoulders of giants do we thereby
become those giants by taking their
advantage of point do we achieve what it
is that they achieve did we attain what
it is a vanity do we have at our
disposal what they did so character
guards ancient men know we're gonna see
why the another issue that comes up is
what is the relationship between
philosophy and faith but also to
theology this I'm not going to talk
quite so much about as a matter of fact
we can sum it up here by saying that
Kierkegaard is actually if you want to
call it the emotion he's a very romantic
theological theologian he prefers faith
to theology because he sees theology as
in a certain way philosophy white it's
doing the same thing as philosophy just
not as well and it's willing to sort of
sell out
ah sweet favors this is a very
interesting thing because you could see
such a big distinction between
Kierkegaard and his view of the faith
and the you know the way in which
philosophy and theology were coordinated
in these so-called age of the Middle
Ages as well the idea was at that time
that theology was the queen of Sciences
and philosophies are handmade in modern
times what we see is the queen falling
at hard times and having to suck up a
lot an awful lot to philosophy in order
to be taken seriously and I think you
can say that still goes on even today so
Kierkegaard has his finger on the pulse
of something here the last big thing
that I want to stress it's a basic note
of this before we delve into it it is
going back to this question about
Christianity and human life it's very
clear in Kierkegaard that the world has
value apart from Christianity the world
has value to some degree if you could
conceive of it this way apart from its
connection to God human life has points
and purposes even if a person is not
this canopy is fully that way can a
person who does not have faith does not
exercise faith can they open themselves
up as fully to reality as the faith us
no but that's not to say that that's
nothing either Kierkegaard thinks that
it is possible to to think to connect
myself to live a life which embraces the
eternal what is eternal in human beings
without having a religion and this is a
very important point variable walk
lesson Christianity or religion in
general gets sort of would an opposition
to the world as if it's everything in
the world there's no good unless unless
you have a Christianity or it denies the
value finite earthly existence or it
becomes its own kind of replacement for
the world Kierkegaard is very far away
from anything like that as a matter of
fact one of the things that he stresses
about Abraham Abraham expected whatever
you want to call a Redemption
fulfillment life being made plentiful
being made good he expected that to
happen
in this life in this world in the world
of finitude in the world of experience
in the world which we know that's part
of what makes his his Stansel
paradoxical
he didn't put it off to a distance
imagined heaven later on down the line
everything else could be said
- now - she said no it's maybe happen
here and her character is saying that as
well about faith so all those three
notes not three all those five notes
pointed out let's look at the structure
of this work the real Colonel round of
this is the section which is involved
[Applause]
three term we get the word problem from
it and literally means something sort of
thrown in front of them which which one
has to that engage yeah the problem out
of session he has four parts there is
what he calls the preliminary
[Applause]
expectation and expectation that's a
Latin word you could think of it
literally as getting something water
just after there
very short somebody has some stuff I'm
going to read a little bit from it in
just a moment before that there is an
accordion and a eulogy now you have
these these classical compositional
order record rhetorical terms being
thrown in the air
why is pure good riddance this work has
a sort of structure to it
the same themes are going to get
reinforced throughout but this is very
typical Kierkegaard he wants to approach
the same problem from from different
angles and different genres allow you to
do that in complementary ways so I don't
think that this is one of those things
where you want to try to break down each
section say what exactly was going on
here only here not in these other
sections because they're finding that
grows in the other sections as well so
let's look first at the exordium
what is going on to them there this is
the after a very very short practice as
well in the x-coordinate says once upon
a time there was a man who has a child
that heard the beautiful story of God
tempted Abraham and how Abraham was
stood the temptation kept the faith and
contrary to expectation giantess on the
same time and it's about this man who
read this
over and over again and as he got older
and older and older
he understood the story less and less
Hospital was more and more passionately
fascinated by them and then Kierkegaard
tells us these four sort of variations
on the story Isaac and Abraham in the
first one he talks about Abraham
you know saddling up the VDS is riding
through three days seeing mom
Araya taking Isaac up to the mountain
and so Abraham explained what's going on
Isaac and Isaac doesn't it doesn't click
with him he begs his father with his
life
Abraham turns around and his face is
wild full horror a terror to his son and
Isaac you know terms of way that Abraham
is actually putting on a show he doesn't
want his he doesn't want his son to give
up on God and his son says
guy who had anniversary I'm a God of
Abraham and mercy on me I have no father
on earth and you be my father and every
on breathes of Prayer thanks to God for
that is that in a biblical tale no
Kierkegaard is sort of exploring and
this is a really interesting thing to
think of them we have all these great
marriages think about not just biblical
tales but also fairy tales when there's
a whole there will be one line talking
about something happening and so much
was going on at that time so much of the
run through people's heads so much would
wait and then they would wrestle
character garters trying to put themself
imaginative the second one Abraham Rises
embraces Sarah he riding takes his so
long and they get to Mount Moriah he
arranges the firewood draws the knife
then he sees the Rama but from that day
Abraham was holy did not forget that God
had ordered him to do this
Isaac flourished as before but Abraham's
eyes were darkened and he saw joy no
more this is a different way of
interpreting the story again is that in
there is that the end of the original
story no Kierkegaard is still trying to
wrap his head around what's going on the
paper and there are several more
variations they don't want I don't want
to go into those too much you can read
those wrong I do want to talk about is
now this eulogy on Avery yeah they talk
about eulogy the modern sense of the
term has really lost some of the meaning
that he had for the ancients for
medievals and even the early modern ISM
that you know into late modernity at the
time of Carragher we think of a eulogy
is something
he's dying after the funeral and anybody
can do it and he just has that like care
about the person there have something
nice to say well that's a little bit of
100 GS
strictly speaking the eulogy means
saying something good about another
person it's a form of praise
Aristotle actually talks about this in
his book one of the examples that the
dictator rhetoric there's three genres
of every rehearsal aerosol thought this
word thing was very very important not
just for funerals eulogies reveal to us
not just how we feel about something
they revealed to us something more
general or lofty more necessary for us
what they reveal is the noble the best
what is to be praised why not to be
praised what is so great about what
qualities and characteristics are
important so he's eulogizing Adrienne
and then why is he doing that well
because Abraham has something special
about him and he tells the story of
Avery
he says Abraham was a man of faith he's
greater than any hero he's greater than
the poet it talks about here he is the
father of faith he is the exemplar of
that so that's what's going on in the
eulogy then we have
so before we actually go into now
dealing with these these themes I'm
going to read a little bit the epilogue
I'm going to skip all the way to to the
end Kierkegaard says faith is the
highest passion in a person there are
perhaps many in every generation who did
not come to faith but no one who goes
further and then he says life has tasks
enough also for the person who has not
come to faith if he loves these honestly
his life will not be wasted even if it
is never comparable the lives of those
who received and grasped the highest but
the person who has come to faith does
not come to a standstill of faith indeed
he would be indignant if anyone said
this to him just as the lover would
resent if someone said that he came to a
standstill in love yet he does not go
further does not go on to something
Alice for what he finds this that he has
another explanation this is a really key
passage this wraps everything up I think
very nicely faith is the highest passion
in a person that's one important point
another important point the person who
exists in faith doesn't stop in faith
it's a finished product that's all blood
at the same time they don't go on to
something else so this is this is a good
time to now shift to looking at how
Keurig are regarded at the current
cultural situation and I think that we
can see a lot of parallels so the
current philosophical or cultural view
that he is criticizing of his time is
what we might call a kind of consumers
philosophy has generated all sorts of
nice products and we can just sort of
appropriate them and make them our own
we can sort of sort of pick up and use
get all the all the meet all the mirror
out of what others have attained this is
a very consumers attitude towards
spiritual life and by spiritual life
that don't just mean religion I'm not
talking about by the way people think
I'm spiritual but not religious for
Kierkegaard religion is part of
spirituality the highest part but
philosophy is part of that as well and
so are other great intellectual things
Kierkegaard's of you is that people with
the end time are kind of expecting other
people to do their work he has a great
sort of discussion of this at the very
beginning the expectation he says he's
talking about people and this hue
doesn't work doesn't doesn't get Brad
doesn't meet he says well in the
external world
that's not the way it actually works
people work and they start but it's
different in the world of spirit here an
eternal divine order prevails here it
does not rain at home for Justin yeah
just here the Sun does not shine on both
good and evil here it holds true that
only the one who works gets bread only
the one who was in anxiety if I dressed
that only the one in a sense the lower
world rescues the beloved
that only the one who draws the knife
gets Isaac he will not work does not get
read it as deceived he talks about the
guys deceiving Cory for this or this is
this this Greek figure whose wife 3 this
guy's or if the work is actually the
sense of the underworld to get her back
and it's whole ok new piano because it
causes a lot of trouble down there but
we can't look back at her on the way up
and they go all the way up all just
about to get out of Hades and then she
stumbles and she cries out
back-attitude she disappears and the
tradition is he was never really heard
was just a phantom he was deceived well
many people are similarly deceived by
thinking that because they buy a book of
Kierkegaard or each other Hegel and they
read something or they go on to Twitter
or Facebook or whatever you like and
chant about philosophy that they have
therefore in my philosophy of a
philosophical life and even for
philosophy parents say that's not true
here's where existential philosophers
particularly and in fact you have to
actually put in the world not just
intellectual work but you might say
emotional affective volitional we have
to reflect we have to commit yourself
and see what happens you have to then
step back and see what we think about
what happened you have to make choices
that are often faithful that closed off
this alternative if you pick this one
you have to also make choices which
reaffirm themselves over and over again
without doing this there are many
lessons many concepts even in philosophy
that just can't make sense for you and
when we get to religion and we get to
the fake Kierkegaard let's say that's
even more the case unless you may
actually do something committers feel
something you are just not going to be
able to fully comprehend what's going on
and seductive thing is you
so like it says nobody can do the work
for another and when it comes to Abraham
that says the story of about Abraham is
remarkable and then it is always a
glorious no matter how poorly is
understood but here again it is a matter
of whether or not we are willing to work
and be burdened but we are unwilling to
work and yet we want to understand the
story must with work unless we do the
work unless we keep doing the work we're
not going to get out of it what is there
to get out it's not something that's
immediate right there for us to just
sort of pick up it takes something so
I'm doing this is an important thing he
also does talk about this in another
point in the epilogue and he's talking
about generations and whether progress
has been made
whatever one generation learns from
another no generation learns the
essentially from a previous one in this
respect each generation begins
primitively
has no task other than what each
previous generation had nor does it
advance further insofar as the previous
generations did not betray the task one
deceive themselves so we begin where
Kierkegaard himself began Kierkegaard
himself begins where Socrates and the
early followers of Christ or Abraham
began we all have to sort of put
ourselves not necessarily archaically
back into that place but existentially
there in that same place if you realize
that that's what it means to really be
human so that's an important thing
what about philosophers well the
philosophy and the culture of character
Derek's
for the most part was taking a position
sort of like this faith is something
that you begin as a starting point
faith is kind of income it's about a
feeling it's about you know the beliefs
that you have you're not quite sure why
it happened it's about hopes or wishes
it's about things that then passed on to
you then you buy into its it's about
pictures it's about images it's about
sentiments narratives all that sort of
stuff
faith is in that sense a speck it's
something which we like basically
subjectively I'm attracted to this can't
stay is that why and if I could stay why
then I probably wouldn't been faithful
to my realized that the reason why I
want to look at my cats is because
they're pretty then why don't I just
look it up if I don't want to go to Mass
because I get kind of a charge of it but
I'm not really concerned about the
sacramentality
like that maybe I should just you know
rock step
those are things can everybod say you
know well it is a little time
faith was being seen as something
preliminary and then once you have faith
either go on from there and do the real
work which is philosophy and Hegel who
like a secretary does criticize Hegel
one sings angle was saying Christianity
as a religion as the sort of religious
part of their religion not the
philosophical part religion is for the
masses it's for ordinary people who are
not really willing to think and need to
be satisfied with with feeling more than
anything else but the real me know that
the real meaning the real rationality
the real greatness of it lies in what a
philosophy can make of it so to do this
although this kind of nice example
because Cagle did not do what many of
the other blademen philosophers did
which is just sort of you know strip all
sorts of things when did a negative way
great example that would be Thomas
Jefferson who was dazed and it would be
much more like the French enlightenment
figures Deus believed that there
couldn't be anything like miracles so
what did he do took his Bible and he
just
passages where they're literally cut
them out then Bible he's still in the
Bible so you still have you know
religion but not even purified in
philosophically Hegel was not quite so
crude as that as a matter of fact Eagle
criticizes that but Hinkle is doing
something similar in his own way he is
saying faith is just a starting point
what you really need to do is understand
the concept you really need to
understand what's going on there and
Kierkegaard talks about this as everyone
wanting to go on further than the faith
that was a common thing in his own time
but I think this is very common in our
time too there is a tendency to take
faith as being something fundamentally
you're irrational to which our job is
now to bring rationality in or pull the
rationality of it now faith is not good
enough by its office motivated for this
and she regarded wants to do something
very different he wants to say that's
the wrong way to philosophy if it's
going to be good philosophy like good
philosophy what I mean here is
philosophy that is true to its own
essence philosophy that takes its
following obligations and tasks
seriously that's obligation and he asked
us to
in reality the human beings placed in it
its own processes and to put all those
into the proper perspective if
philosophy is going to do that then it
has to realize that faith to remain
something kind of a limit kind of a
threshold that it can go up to but it
can't get past they can't get further
this is a very different conception of
the relationship between philosophy
paganism this is the conception that
Heidegger that connects our interior is
according forth here and the faith that
he one other thing anyone's interest the
faith that he's talking about it's not
actually some purely rational as shot of
the dark jumping to God knows what it's
actually an embrace everything else
finitude of where we are the human
condition
and certainly faith can embrace the
human condition in a way that philosophy
can only wish that so let's go on about
that introduces another important idea
and we're going to get to the night of
faith in just a moment the night of
faith
information but before that I want to
talk about - Kierkegaard conceives of
faith has the highest passion and he
says that reflection by itself thinking
that it doesn't do anything it doesn't
accomplish it
it doesn't produce passion commits being
cold being attracted being driven is
something that's required and he says
the highest passion is faith but he does
talk about several other passions that
are very important in here he talks
about irony and humor as passions which
are also to something reflective they
are good there's something to them but
they're not going to get you or fade
this and if we want to think about in
terms of this mentality of grasping like
passions not just intellectually not
just thinking not just speculation but
passions feelings commitments living
actor those are what revealed to us the
world who we are who other people are
what else is out here where are things
lacking we are things where things good
what should be done
it's not just thinking that reveals that
it's passion and irony and humor
revealed to us sides of the world that
pure flock by itself wouldn't do but it
doesn't do what it is that faith with us
what are some other caches long love is
a passion as well and Kierkegaard says
you can tell the hero and the greatness
of the hero by what it is that they love
there are many things we could love many
goods in this world do we want the
highest one do we love the one that's
most worthwhile there are many things
for which you could sacrifice yourself
or commit yourself or sell everything
else do you pick the right one
depending on how you love and what you
love the world will look different to
you you will open up sides to you than
otherwise you might not see what else
joy and of course you know it's within
the very title fear fear is itself a
passion this is interesting because
Heidegger another existentialist
philosopher who I would say in many ways
more indebted to nature than he was
hiding her my sense of Kierkegaard he is
going to take a certain type of
affection which is connected with fear
and make that one the one that reveals
everything certain passion anxiety
Kierkegaard doesn't do that it's faith
but fear is important because what is
the what is the lip sign of fear what is
connected and yet opposed courage you
know I do want to hit on something that
does say about courage actually a few
different things talking about himself
talking about the
the process that he's engaged in here in
this boy and I think that this is also a
great thing to think about when it comes
to philosophy particularly
existentialist philosophy he says yes
for me I do not lack the courage to
think a complete thought up until now I
have feared not in the question
encounter such a one I don't that I
would least would have any honesty to
say this thought makes me afraid it
shocks me therefore I will not think it
we live many of us in denial we are
unwilling to fully think about thoughts
we are unwilling to rely on the
resources that are out there to fully
think about including our own passion of
life there are many things which we
wanted to fully understand things we
would have to think but if they make us
uncomfortable
we shy and that's a lack of courage
intellectual courage doesn't just mean
taking people off or risking death it
means throwing yourself into the balance
throwing your very few of yourself
throwing your evaluation of their son
into the balance that's that's what kind
of adults security guards they keep
saying either where else is he talking
about courage well he talks about
courage in terms of the two nights and
night of faith in the nation in talking
about the night of an infinite
resignation he says he's not currently
he's not afraid to let it which is the
things that he loves and they're
vulnerable
lose them and maybe block from them
forever he does not well that he's not
afraid to let it steal into his his most
secret his most remote clock to let him
twist minute why did saw intricately
around every ligament of his
consciousness if his log comes to grief
you will never be able to wrench itself
out of it that is part of what it means
to be a philosopher it's not just to
read if Russell or Conte it's not enough
to him you know try to have their
thoughts imaginatively for a little
while it involves self scrutiny it
involves looking at where one is
vulnerable what one is attracted to what
good things one would like to have even
flaws but fears the loss of and to allow
that to actually go into what self
removing removing the armor moving all
those things that stand in the way of
genuine self knowledge that's probably
what it requires to be what he calls the
negative
resignation he also talks about courage
and a few other points he he says that
the point of this whole exercise is to
perceive the greatness of what Abraham
did so that the person can judge for
himself whether he has the location and
the courage to be tried and something
like this
so again Abraham and then finally
earlier on the expectoration there's one
passage where is again contrasting the
night of resignation which appears to be
yeah yeah the night that faith that he
says I have seen the terrifying face to
face and I do not believe from it before
but I know very well that even though I
have advanced towards it courageously my
courage is still not the courage of
faith and it's not something to be
compared with it I cannot make the
movement of faith I cannot shut my eyes
and plunge confidently into the absurd
it is for me a possibility but I do not
praise myself for that
so there's there's two types of courage
perhaps there's there's a lesser courage
and a greater courage and the lesser
courage is maybe a reflection or
the greater courage which the person of
faith comes to trust in the absurd to
trust in God so now let's actually talk
about is being opposition's set of ideas
your carrot is using terms like night in
part because they evoke Shohreh they
have a commitment they have over time in
which the individual now before we
explore these let's look at some other
ways of life some other alternatives
that are not either these this is the
best the night of faith this is the
second best if you can't be this then
you're greater saying and you really
want to live a truly life be this don't
be the other things one of the things
that he talks about is not necessarily
bad it's just not fully developed he
contrasts faith with naivety and here's
something important in order to be a
night of faith in order to have faith
you have to actually be asked through
the point of infinite resignation Quran
to Kierkegaard that may be something
more a lot of other religious people
don't necessarily agree with dinner
Kierkegaard says precisely because
resignation is the antecedent the faith
is no aesthetic emotion but something
far higher it is not the spontaneous
inclination of the heart but the paradox
of existence if for example on the face
of every different
young girls no remains convinced that
her desire will be fulfilled this
assurances by no means the assurance of
faith even though she has been brought
up by Christian parents and perhaps
she's had confirmation instructions from
the pastor for a whole year why not she
is convinced in all her childlike
naivete and innocence and this assurance
and normals from nature gives us
supernatural magnitudes of ellika
thaumaturge she can invoke the finite
cars of existence and bring the very
stones to tears she's not saying this a
bad thing
he's not saying I'll get rid of
innocence you know wipe it out so that
we can all be clever and you know give
it quickly as we can to know the matter
of fact that's it that's a great thing
it's just not what faith is
you know lacks a certain path there's a
certain depth he says her assurance is
the most captivating and one can learn
much from her but there's one thing that
cannot be learned from her how to make
movements she doesn't if you over the
pain of resignation she doesn't feel the
loss she is not fully aware of the
condition that's a you know a fairly
good thing to practice
now let's we'll get some other things
which are not faith and resignation one
of these would be what we could call
faith faith or to use a
another term cheap grace writing some of
these cocktails you might say he says
the last is to go through the peak that
abraham stands on the last stage to pass
from his view is the stage of infant
resignation
all those travesties of faith the
wretched lukewarm lethargy that thinks
there's no emergency there's no use in
grieving beforehand the despicable hope
that says one just can't know what will
happen it could possibly be
these travesties are native to the
paltry nests of life that an infinite
resignation is already infinitely
sustainment so the ninth Infinite
resignation before one Kristy's faith is
going to give up on any service
well you know maybe things in turn okay
God you know God's up there to have
anything to do sort of a fatalistic
attitude non serious attitude as well as
a sort of uncommitted lethargy finally
there's another thing that he talks
about
and then again you're talking about the
main evented resignation here what
distinguishes that night of infinite
resignation from some other types of
people he says well the night of
infinite resignation has committed
themselves they have gone through the
process in which they thought about
goods and what is necessary says in the
first place that night will have the
power to concentrate the whole substance
of his life and meaning of actuality
into one single desire that's very
important one single desire denied them
to the resignation looking for one good
and they've looked at them they decided
and they figured out this is the best
good
me this is the one thing necessary to
use a biblical term so he's concentrated
the whole substance of his life and
meaning in actuality into one single
designer here's the contrast if a person
who lacks this concentration is focused
his soul is dissipated in multiplicity
from the beginning and then he never
manages to make the movement he acts as
shrewdly in life as a finance Ayers who
put the resources into widely
diversified investments in order to gain
a lot if they lose on another ensure
he's not night not only does the night
do this with their desire they do this
with their thought with their
consciousness he says in the next place
the night will have the power to
concentrate that included of all is
thinking into one act of consciousness
if he lacks this focus his soul is
dissipated in multiplicity from the
beginning and he will never find time to
make a movement the movement da infinite
resignation
[Music]
you will never find time to make the
movements you will continually be
running errands in life and will never
enter it into the eternity it's the
concentration on one good one desire
placing that into the balance and
knowing you may not get and knowing that
you do get it it may not have anything
to do with your worthiness of getting it
and it may not be something that you
keep forever and be able came becoming
infinitely resigned
that's the preparatory move for faith
because that's the preparatory move that
fully introduces you into what here
Kierkegaard calls
eternal what its fertile in human beings
this he says if you can do this is what
philosophy what to do
that's all philosophy can do that that's
as far as I can get it probably have to
ask well how is all this stuff about
faith that's let's look at a few more
characterizations of the infinite
resignation she has this great
comparison he talks about the night's
been affinity who have renounced their
desire and yet they still enjoy who are
okay with the things who have worked
themselves into that sort of state where
things make sense where even their
suffering make sense he says there are
sort of like ballet dancers there are
ballet dancers the most difficult data
feed from ballet dancers to leap into a
specific posture in such a way that he
never once strains for the posture but
in the very latest students the posture
the nights of infinity the nights of
infinite resignation come very very
close to doing that but as they shift
into the postural
what is the posture posture is
acceptance not just intellectual but
effective national and there's always a
little bit of [ __ ] there's always a
little bit of glimmer there's always
something that gives them away and this
is where the night of faith is in some
ways very close to what is best in us
they grasp the world they grasp reality
like it says what I gain in resignation
is my internal consciousness this is a
purely philosophical movement that I
ventured to make what it is demanded and
Candice's of myself to make because
every time some finitude will take
probably i starved myself of a
submission until I make for my eternal
conscious consciousness is my love for
God and for me that is the highest of
all that's not yet faith so let's move
on to what is the made of faith and here
purity Verity has this just brilliant
depiction of him the night of faith
there's two things that I want to stress
one is the night of faith has faith in
God the end in the absurd and these are
one the ninth eighth things that God
cares about everything and we'll somehow
who knows how make things turn out the
way that they ought to and so they can
love the world and they can love the
finitude world in a way that the ninth
of infinite resignation is unable to do
they can trust in God and God's capacity
to make things sort out
even when it seems totally impossible to
live sir in a way the confederate
reservation because of them like I said
they didn't love the finite they can be
okay with things in a national way in an
effective way that reveals to them the
true size of the world in a way that's
not possible for the Native Americans
information I'm going to read you a
passage it's one of my favorite of this
book he says the Knights of the infinite
resignation are easily recognizable
their walk it's light and bold but they
care they will carry the treasure to
fade they're likely to disappoint
externally they have striking
resemblance to word walk fullest in ISM
which infinite resignation like faith
deeply disdains and so eg introduces
this this character would be the knight
affinity says here he is the
acquaintances maiden introduced him the
instant I laid eyes on him I said if a
product once but jumped back clap my
hands and say half aloud good Lord is
this the man is this really the one he
looks just like a tax collector but this
is indeed only the one I move a little
closer to watch the slightest movement
to see if it reveals a bit of
heterogeneous optical telegraphy from
the infinite a glance of facial
expression a gesture a Santa's who
swallowed the trade infinite and its
heterogeneity with the planet no the
examine his figure from the top to toe
to see if there may not be a crack
through which in another peak know if
you saw it all the way through and he
says he takes pleasure and everything
takes a part in everything and every
time one sees in purchase
at something particular he does it with
an assiduous miss that marks the worldly
man who was attached to these things he
attempts to his job
he goes to church in the afternoon he
takes a walk to the woods he enjoys
everything he sees the swarms of people
the new Honda buses the sound
encountering about Strad van one who had
taken from mercantile slalom join us he
finds pleasure in this way he's not a
poet towards the evening he goes home
this is my favorite part of him this is
so telling towards the evening he goes
moment as gauges his studies and post
minutes on his way he thinks his wife
truly of the special hawk milder and
then he comes home for example roast
lamb said with vegetables if he meets a
kindred soul he would go on talking all
the way to poster part about this
delicacy whether the action befitting a
restaurant operator it's so it happens
he does metaphor shillings to his name
yet he firmly believes that his wife has
this delectable meal waiting for him if
she has to see him he would be the envy
of the elite in an inspiration of common
man for his appetite is keener than
Vsauce his wife does jnana curiously
enough he is just the scene on the
waiting passes a building site that
meets another man they converse for a
moment in' in an instant he directs a
building and he has this position
everything required he says with the
freedom from cure of a reckless
good-for-nothing he lets things take
care of themselves and yet every moment
of his life he buys the opportune time
at the highest price for he does not do
him even the slightest thing
by virtue of the absurd and yet yes I
could be infuriated over there for no
other isn't an entity this man has made
and that everyone is making the movement
of infinity he drains the deep sadness
of life in infinite resignation he knows
the blessedness of infinity he has felt
the pain of pronouncing everything the
most precious things in the world and
yet the finite here's the key thing the
finite tastes just as good as one who
never knew anything higher because his
remaining infinitude would have no trace
of the timorous anxious routine and yet
he has the security that makes him
delight in it as a finitude with the
surest thing of all this is what faith
is he has resigned everything infinitely
and then he has grasped everything again
by virtue of the absurd so this is
something really key what it is to have
faith is not just a sort of irrational
blind commitment it is actually to like
he says renounce everything and get
it's back because it won't trust it to
be willing that's why Abraham is a
picture of us what did Abraham do if you
think about it story this is where we're
going to death
Abraham was commanded by God not just to
you know take this booter that glitter
this way but to take the placement the
best thing because almost son the son of
promise the son that everything depended
of God said things like I'm going to
make you the father of many peoples he
gave a son to his Sarah and her old age
so that she could actually feel
fulfilled that she trusted him in Hebrew
him trusted and then God says I really
can't get out you have to give it up and
not just give it up right now you
actually have to make the movements you
have to go over there that's four days
journey to not four and you have to
sacrifice your son you have to do the
actual movements the processes you have
to do them this way God tests and
Abraham passes the test precisely by
going through infinite resignation and
then trust this is where one regains the
final no longer as the finite just by
itself that would be in a world away but
as part of the internet have satisfying
what is infinite and eternal in Athens
so that's where we're going to leave off
next we're actually going to discuss
these three famous pro LaMotta and we're
going to look at first the teleological
suspension